hello my name is Keegan I'm code game
design after I was - and today I
explained uses my future
the spy feature is a totally new feature
in tribal wars it is about getting
informations from your enemies and from
the variant villages so it's always
important if you attack someone so
you're not taking flight so you need
informations and informations about
what's in the village units or these
buildings stuff like this intro was one
there was the scouts and the scouts were
included in there I'm in management and
we want to skip that so we take them off
and now put them in a special building
the new buildings are tavern and there
you can recruit your spies and use your
spies and we made that you have like a
small squad of spice or it's more
realistic so you have a few spies and
you send them on missions and doing this
stuff it's really important for you that
you have some spice where you have
defense in your village in your tavern
you have different countermeasures way
which you can put on so you're giving
your enemies false informations so he if
he might get spying you and he get a
report you might get a rum report we
have also the camouflage which can hide
and building or you can have a building
so you can decide if especially a
building should have a special level so
you can hide a building or you can show
that you have a building which you don't
have so enemies things you don't have a
wall and then you just have a wall of 20
or 15 the special countermeasure is
exchanged so it's a possibility
if someone attacking you that you get
informations from your enemy so also
it's interesting if you attack someone
you have to keep in mind and if you
attack him and you just attack with one
or two spies and you're doing a really
high-risk
he might have exchange countermeasure so
he will get informations about you will
and your units so be aware of that so
you're not doing like suicide spying was
one spy I hope you will like the new
feature with the spice and the tavern
and don't forget to pre-register H on
our webpage